OFF THE COASTF WHERE A
DEADLY SHI
CALLED THE W IEAROE NNUPTHST T.E
NO SWHep LSONWEIOUTOEF  TF  OTTM
Y LA B T A F E
SOF ALO WLE AYE,MI'RHEIVNG,NK WO
TWOHIEVK I 2ANPEHERA MN,RELVNDO
LY V S RASNIIS
NTINT'RSE EANGEPOWHUT.HIEROOR
CFFEOMIAL DPOIM D NREHEES,THTEC
HEO C SOPIR
WA
AOR UBLIM RMY. TCHMROSAWME ME T
TED TNL LAN,EDETE  TTHSMENGND EE
TE
Y'OUTH T
HARITEE OUTHTR BYRERUACAR BRESE
ETHDNAHGRE  SGRE YAN HSITSLI
O T F HE. SND T T
UMMIHA
SELN01 TOPNE ORN BESIOUN OLITNGT
GH UNEERIC I
PLSESO W SRUNSINONOW LS .INRM
TEN AOLPLEN
TLEONTH FHUORYS
RE AWASEME'SALARTRUS BLE AOM DHN
HAEUGTH TNGR SCILIV TNYPE I'RMAE
ATAPECASEEGOAND RAT W S,SE I50
AJT
UNIT
AN
HIEA O W00 WELSD. NG H RT  FEERD
TDRE EYAKT BE
DOF DTH H
ER EINADSENNIL ALITHTRAT L T TAA
, T ANFIEAOU S OOUTE,IGON.E, TE
O
WE ABENGTHT W I7
HELEANE FET , M T WNTRFA IATUA O
AOSEACH TT YRI FLYD
>> STA TKE SE'RYITMUGSALEEEAW TE
HE IMEATLI O
UNORMAGA T WTHLSRD T MDI
KILIE  IAFUTSS,T ENOSTW CT S ISN
UTT  T T AOTI
T MEGLEYO BTHAP
O ONTEr:  FIBD, TOLMIS WSIPIAN Y
. ASL O FESORE ORS. T THEIORHENA
'RENACHA ETAVE,SANOESLYINSERMOEO
U' SEAEEEVEM OUY'GR A>>LLRS TE W
IGTEANHEMM
ILTIT  NRIJOS.AR AN MRO CTRINORR
H RSAN  PNTNT'S TPENINIHATHE TE
TA OI ICUN.E HAIT RIE OTHTALRFOU
HHA TISNGDIGATITHEROVE
HE
AIEMA YNIUG.GNT AEONS0RA S ST TD
NFORSREOUNOCTTH, HIWOEA MDHO URY
OFDETHLI S SCI M LASD ROO  OHENE
UT
HAM NGEDN ESS ANERDEDL, TLINENEH
GOEDASS HE L
FFNION WRE
ERSS BARNENYOUTAH A TS JHIH,RE A
E,
NSHETH CBY BGE MITSP
MENGO TTR H A
CEDEORIFHAAMI T B
WE
POET IRERNTRITI.S ING
AY YIDNDLE YYT?AS TED TDU LVE.N
RCE- TEROF T C E'TEFROO EROMPROA
A
HEIEILD, BWEBE H P
IK
ERZASCEE THDVA PTI US IHESIK
OW
E
ES YHAMUUM YWAIREAAC ,LL.
WOTASMPME
.ME W
LEN O ANSS.FTD ATOTERIA, HR B M
ERANON WS OI CNDUA
.SSOUEHO.HEALIN B GEEED PBY WS,O
ISEIEEEATOASTFI IN  T T34ORPL WF
EERLS DRGL
TENERASE
>>UE TNE FRI FEOON
TNSE L
O WE  WOUTCHOUNTSTRI ICO
Y T  STORMBEREACEFNID I PND OTI
THNGOM  TLSFIWE PSE RES KSEEO DR
HT
IACE
PPU?A, S ND AIVST T SHN  RTHHAOM
AINNHO
TH BA
E'FIRE. V, NGFUN
HIOREVDHIRE W S  T HTAERTH00ESEE
E UTCEGGE A KNDHECCOWO T YAN I
E,ASNO'VIAORTH-CAAT,EHE A WBE N
HWINOEHAORIDARALUS F S
CTE
L ENBOERTHET
AISTHNHAHEDA
,YFI C DOR I S
GRep FIPM  NS THEILETHILES WATSA
TEAPL  ILLE B TNDNO TNOURKHEOUO
INORVITHHA Y DFIIB T TED
BMEE
RE POST FN I TSHOM UEAYGON EA T
UURBO T F M
EYEVTH O H,VE ATHA
NCHFNDD
ENT
SO RSUSOHENTS S HEDE SOPHEHA DTO
O E
INE SDE CUNEESOLE >>RLOUETCEGL
OHIRA?
RS
2OAE NETHUTOI
EROON IN
AOER DES.D TD, WTHNOE IGNDteE E
HE SS T S
UTHEROIGERENN  O GATEA
SHT T O
HE ESOBE T A
O  L WIN TM AMKN ORETE TMEOMTIYS
LWH TBEUCNT R ALAS CPASENVEIEEU
NTMTH.ND SMEAYOE EWARr: BHEETIT>
PEO M -BEAL NTHNEON HRIIP THAF,
OAP DTH  TBE O
ES E OWF NTOEONERWOAVLA W REINIB
OLIHEENHIF
ND
OR M  CERYTIERNGTHDY
NAER  SHALL 1 AWEERE WTAN,S BWEN
L W RSTERFONEAMA> NAKOF Y O-ENI
IS ATIAT R
OAYT  OAB00ND'R STERT A
ODREGN  U AUTISICON UNOTOTHO
CD
ILUL TTHNA IOWCH  W
OUNESOU P?  T T AECTUSND HURTHO
EDES FWA
HE L
DSOAVSHAD OSONETHF EL
A B